si la récolte de certaines cultures
maraîchères a été mécanisée depuis belle
lurette on n'a qu'à penser aux carottes
ou aux pommes de terre certains légumes
ont résisté longtemps à l'automatisation
c'est le cas du brocoli mais une
nouvelle machine pourrait venir au
secours des agriculteurs qui vivent un
manque criant de main d'oeuvre la voici
à l'oeuvre chez le plus grand producteur
de brocoli au canada
[Musique]
je vais moi même récolter des légumes
pendant quelques saisons étant de l'est
puis à l'été 2008
je suis retourné dans les champs puis
j'ai vu j'ai vu qu'on les genres et côté
des briques audi puis il m'évite n'en a
pas être question à savoir
c'est quoi récolter un brocoli donc j'ai
décortiqué les étapes de récolte d'un
break audi qui est ni plus ni moins
devoir de réfléchir d'analyser donc une
partie d'intelligence puis un geste
d'aller cueillir avec une main puis de
déposer sur un convoyeur
et une partie mécanique une partie
vision une partie intelligence dans ce
donc j'ai regroupé un groupe de
partenaires puis on a développé le celi
on a travaillé sur une première version
qui a permet vraiment de démontrer que
de façon assez simple avec un équipement
minimal dé montrer qu'on est capable de
détecter un brocoli parmi toutes les
feuilles vous avez probablement vu la
quantité de failles qu'il peut y avoir
et le système apprend qu on lui donne
deux contextes variés des situations par
exemple où il a plu des situations où
l'environnement est plutôt sont donc il
fait noir le système fonctionne de ne
peut fonctionner de nuit
des situations il ya de l'ombre âge sont
montre un système où sont des brocolis
dans toutes sortes de contexte donc on
lui montre beaucoup d'imagés brocoli et
une fois qu'on a ce lot 2 ou gros lot
d'image on peut entraîner un modèle qui
après on lui fournit des images et nous
dit le brocoli il y à tel endroit dans
le
dos
si paris le brocoli est un bon candidat
à les récoltes automatise rire baptisé
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit avec une
vision de l'auteur ses fleurs mais on
peut le voir de haut et puis pour venir
le saisir bien on est capable de le
manipuler sans trop le bolide lui
on avait une expérimentation l'année par
aussi qu'étant en statique donc on
avance on arrête le tracteur ont saisi
on a commencé par prendre des images
avec un petit pick up puis
quatre par quatre en bovins de caméras
au bout juste pour s'assurer qu'on
prenait des images puisque tu as offensé
fait une plateforme monté sur trois
points sur une hydraulique de très peur
pour mettre mon équipement une table
ingénieurs avec son ordinateur un robot
à côté qui nous avait été prescrit par
le service
cette année on a mis au point la version
démonstrateur c'est un quatre robots
qu'on a mis en place ou le tout les
technologies sont embarqués une station
robotisée c'est une caméra c'est un
robot sans compréhension et tous
souhaitent en mesure de faire le même
travail à la même cadence qu'un
cueilleurs actuellement en chant dont
six cuillères va récolter deux à la fois
mon robot va aussi récolté ses deux
reins la fois la caméra située à
quelques dizaines de centimètres du
robot le tracteur le robot la caméra se
déplace tous en même temps puis dans
kung fu venir déclencher la cueillette
au bon moment donc faut avoir la
capacité de traquer le brocoli
l'avancent du tracteur et puis dans le
fond faut aussi venir ramasser les
brocolis lui-même donc faut venir
rebaptisé le procédé de ses hits brocoli
et le procédé de coupe dans le fond par
gedo
c'est sur quel projet fou qui soit
rentable pour
procéder à un achat de d'une gare
d'anvers que je pense qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à améliorer mais je
crois qu'ils vont ils vont finir par y
arriver deux ayant les meilleurs
l'avancement du drakkar vaut à peu près
à la même vitesse que les récolteurs
actuel puis le robot une efficacité de
récolte donc un brocoli à toutes les 4
secondes présente et reste un peu
d'ajustements fer ont mis trois secondes
peut-être avoir besoin d'un statut
financier pour pourrait passer une
grosse portion de risque la première ni
chauffage ni mes 60 travailleurs qui
récolte les brocolis s'ils viennent pas
mais il faut que je sois capable de
récolter avec avec le samu faut que ce
soit 100% sûr s'il amène la machine à
venise pendant deux jours un brocoli une
journée lendemain est plus bon
un robot ça peut travailler 24 heures
sur 24 un robot sait jamais fatigué
s'est jamais d'année c'est toujours
actif et puis il n'y a pas de pas de
répit sur un rebond on veut faire
plusieurs tâches en chant on peut
envisager d'avoir uniquement le système
de caméra d'intelligence artificielle et
il faire détecter
des mauvaises elles des taux de
rendement ils faire détecter des
champignons des insectes soit des
insectes eux mêmes ou plutôt les
dommages causés par les insectes donc
pas juste la récolte bel et bien on
pourrait voir passer des mauvaises
herbes puis enlever la main préhension
sur une poignée de robot puis adapté un
outil pour désherber et à partir de là
même demandé à notre tablette de
désherber un champ de brocoli un besoin
qui est grandissante parce que les
problèmes de main d'oeuvre on commence à
en parler mais c'est c'est un problème
qui s'en voit de plus en plus en
importance donc si on veut une solution
futur il faut commencer à la préparer
aujourd'hui pour avoir les outils demain
pour être trader
doit récolter les brocolis de thomas ni
plus ni moins ce qu'on est en train de
faire avec ça c'est de transférer des
jobs manuel dans des champs vers des job
d'ingénieur vendée globe